you did Schneider and Robin Lacan
shooting a new video for their YouTube
channel it's a sort of making off for
their unusual hobby they reenact scenes
from popular movies in the locations
where they were shot we're to take
another picture this is the picture
we're after the scene is from the comedy
rabbit without ears one of the most
successful German language films
recently a scene for what was shot in a
church in Potsdam near Berlin the couple
have to come up from Hessen for the
weekend to stage the scene in the
original location but as soon as they
arrive they run into difficulties here
at around 1 or 2 o'clock in the
afternoon so the shadow is pointing
almost directly at us they wanted to
look just as it did in the movie down to
the last detail they even make the
costumes themselves she's not wearing
much just a skirt a cardigan and
pantyhose it's pretty cold today but
we're not going to let the clothes stop
us we'll just have to do it the couple
decided to show the process of achieving
the perfect image on their YouTube
channel they used science fiction films
like The Hunger Games and inception as
examples it often takes a lot of effort
to reproduce the same position and it
can be difficult to even if it looks
simple the pose from inception was
really hard because it's from a movement
the man is bending towards the woman and
she's tilting her head back we have to
hold this position and I have to bend my
head down in this strange way this photo
reenact the Hunger Games Mockingjay it
was also taken in Berlin to get other
shots they've traveled halfway around
the world
Vivint here we are in New Zealand's
Fiordland in New Zealand we put together
a photo from 10,000 BC these were people
who'd live 10,000 years before Christ
the woman had this huge hood on made of
something that was a little shiny
accountable costume serves as a designer
skirt here as seen from the US TV series
Sex in the City
a purple bathrobe imitates an outfit
from the British TV series Downton Abbey
even the smallest props can make a
difference as in the movie alien
covenant shot in New Zealand but who
took the picture the automatic shutter
release the couple shot the photo in
Potsdam the same way this is the result
[Music]